- [Mark] Let me share with you
why I love oxtail so much.
It is this. (exhales shakily )
The meat just falls.
It just pulls off. Look at that.
(upbeat tempo music)
- Good morning everyone, it's Mark Wiens
with migrationology.com in Rome, Italy.
We are walking right now
through the Piazza di Spagna
and on our way to the
Pantheon this morning
and we're gonna walk around
that area for the morning
and just explore
and then later on, early this afternoon,
I already booked tickets online for 1:00pm
and we are gonna to
visit the Vatican City.
(upbeat tempo music)
If you don't follow your
map, like on your cell phone
or follow it, you will definitely get lost
within these alleys and streets.
They're so confusing back here
but it's amazing. (exhales)
And just the view of the
Pantheon in front of me now.
But I'm going to go have a coffee
before I talk more about the Pantheon.
There's a coffee spot that
is just a couple of meters
from the Pantheon and
it's a pretty fast affair.
You can't really hang out and drink coffee
but what you do, you stand
in there, you order a coffee
and just at the bar you drink your coffee.
So it's going to be
pretty fast and furious.
I'm going to give Ying the camera
because Ying doesn't drink coffee
and she's going to follow me in there
and then I'm going to have
a cup of coffee real fast.
(people chatting in background)
(dishes clinking)
(speaking in foreign language)
So what you do is you pay at the cashier
and you get a receipt
and then you come over to the coffee bar
and then they make your orders.
(dishes clinking)
My first cup.
(people chatting in background)
Oh that's an awesome cup of coffee.
Oh yeah. That is fantastic.
(dishes clinking)
And I had ordered one more.
(people chatting in background)
That's just absolutely stunning.
It is like...
It's strong, it's a little bit foamy
and just extremely flavorful.
I'm loving this.
Yes, so you've gotta
drink it kind of fast.
You're just standing here, you drink it
and then you leave.
It's a fast affair.
(dishes clinking)
That was some incredibly
high quality Espesso.
Absolutely delicious and that
was a very necessary stop.
(upbeat tempo music)
(water trickling)
It's just incredible to think
that it was built over 2,000 years ago
and it's such a grand structure
with the Corinthian columns in the front
and the whole circular Pantheon
and also what I was reading
is that it is a concrete dome on the top.
And it's un-reinforced and even today,
2,000 years after it was built,
it remains the largest
un-reinforced concrete dome in the world.
And just, the entire circular structure.
And then the dome which is covering it.
Plus the opening right at
the very top, the Oculus.
This is absolutely an engineering
and construction marvel.
(upbeat tempo music)
And when you see people
come in for the first time
you just see everyone
with their cameras out
and just doing full 360s circling around.
You can't help but do that
because it's such an
awe-inspiring structure.
(upbeat tempo music)
(water tricking)
Since we happen to be in this area,
there's a very famous Gelato shop
that has 150 different flavors.
Ying, are you ready for some Gelato?
(upbeat tempo music)
- [Server] And the flavors please.
- [Mark] Can I have one of this.
The (mumbles)
- [Server] Yeah, and the next?
- [Mark] And the other one, pistachio.
- [Server] Would you like
that with cream on top,
the whip cream?
- [Mark] Do you want anything on top?
- Thank you.
- Have a good day.
- [Mark] Thank you, have a good day.
Whoa. Whoa Ying.
(speaks in foreign language)
(Mark laughs)
- [Ying] Mmmm.
(Mark mumbles)
- Ying got half.
I think this is mixed
berry and then pistachio.
This is a pretty good size.
This is the medium size.
Wow.
Okay, that is pretty awesome.
The flavor is so well pronounced
and then again, it's so creamy.
I think I probably have some on my chin.
Okay next, (mumbles) for that berry.
Wow. Yeah.
That is amazing
And there's so much real...
You can taste so much
real berries in there.
The little raspberry seeds
and the creaminess and
the sweetness and the...
Yeah, that is some highly good Gelato.
(upbeat tempo music)
Ying especially loved that Gelato.
(laughing)
Was it the best Gelato Ying?
- Yes.
- There is another famous coffee shop
on the opposite side of the Pantheon.
That's where we are headed now.
I could use another shot of Expresso.
Same drill.
I'm gonna go in there,
pay, take my receipt,
stand there at the bar,
slurp down my cup of coffee
and that's the process.
(people chatting in background)
- [Server] Thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you.
- A fresh cup of (mumbles).
(speaks in foreign language)
- Oh wow.
There is no milk in here
but it's almost like foamy.
Like ice cream foamy.
Wow, that is impressively awesome.
(people chatting in background)
I managed to slurp most of that foam
but you gotta use your spoon
to grab the rest of it.
You don't want any of
it to be left behind.
Alright, that was awesome.
That was one of those beverages
that I wish I had on an IV.
I just want a constant of
that Espresso in my system.
(upbeat tempo music)
That is an awesome one seater car.
We wound our way through
some of the alleys
and we finally found it.
Gonna have some pizza.
- [Server] That side?
- [Mark] Yeah. Yes please.
Yeah sure.
(knife blade thuds)
- That is it?
- [Mark] And, do you have
another one with more toppings
or not ready yet?
- Just a minute
- [Mark] Okay.
- So you can begin with this one
and in two minutes I'll
have more pizza, okay.
[Mark] Okay.
This place makes pizza but
it's also a full bakery
and so you walk in here
and the aroma of baking bread
just fills your nostrils.
We're here a little bit early
so not all of different
topping pizzas are ready yet
but he said that we should
start with this pizza first
and wait to see a few minutes
for some of the flavors
that might come out of the oven.
The tomato sauce, the cheese.
Wow. Mm-hmm.
The bread is absolutely perfect.
It's crusty and then kind of gummy.
And then the tomato sauce
is a little bit tart
but the vibrancy of those tomatoes.
The cheese is not too salty
and it's in slices so that
an entire chunk of cheese
just came up on that bite.
It's just a pure harmony of flavors.
- [Server] Like this?
- [Mark] Yes.
- [Server] Okay.
- [Mark] And maybe small slice of spinach.
- [Server] Yes, right away.
- [Mark] Can I have it to go?
- [Server] Certainly.
- [Mark] A little less. Yes.
And so you just point out what you want.
He'll chop a piece off
and you can either eat it right inside
like we had that first
warm up pizza for inside
but then for our next pizza,
I decided to get it for take away
because we might walk while we eat
and also I wanted to stand
outside and enjoy this ambiance.
It's a shape of the pizza.
It comes like this and
this one includes...
Look at all those toppings.
This one includes lots
of cheese, mushrooms
and I'm not sure what that is.
Some kind of meat.
But this one looks awesome
and, actually,
I think what you do
is that you kind of eat it sandwich style
because all those toppings
are squished in the middle.
(paper scrunching)
- So, yeah,
I don't want to risk losing
any of those toppings
so I'm just going to fold it up
but you just have to get a close up look
at all those goodies inside of there.
Just look how special that is.
Look at that, wow.
(people chatting in background)
Wow.
That is spectacular.
The cheese is packed with mushrooms.
That's some type of sausage type of meat
with a little bit of sourness to it.
The bread, it's so crisp,
but then it's gummy
where the cheese meets bread.
Okay next one.
(paper scrunching)
And this next one,
I believe it's the spinach one.
Oh yeah, this is the spinach.
That's just like a little
sandwich with spinach and cheese.
Oh that's beautiful too.
(paper scrunching)
Oh yeah, if you love spinach,
you're gonna to love this.
This is pure and just loaded
with handfuls of spinach and cheese.
The thing that stood out to
me the most was the bread.
The bread, the crust, was incredible.
I don't think you can go wrong
with anything at Roscioli.
(upbeat tempo music)
We have just walked into Campo de' Fiori.
This is another square.
Another many of the plazas in Rome
and this one is famous because
it is home to a fresh market.
There are lots of fruits
and vegetables, spices.
You can buy lots of things here
and we are just actually,
kind of just passing through though.
(upbeat tempo music)
We made it to the Tiber river.
We are crossing the bridge now.
We're getting very close
to the Vatican city.
(upbeat tempo music)
And the Vatican city is a city state,
a walled in city state within Rome.
And it is of course ruled
by the head bishop of Rome
who is the Pope.
And so we are walking with
the front main entrance view
but I think the main
entrance is on the other side
where all of the people are walking
so that's where we're going to go.
Okay, that was a little bit of a walk
from the entrance to the
Vatican museum entrance.
You have to go around the wall
but we are approaching now.
We got through security
and then we transferred our e-ticket
into the little tickets.
It kind of felt like immigration.
(upbeat tempo music)
This museum is huge.
It's one of the largest
art gallery museums
in the entire world.
I don't know if we will
be able to see everything
but I'm gonna kind of pick
and choose some of the important things
or things that I really want to see.
(upbeat tempo music)
We are passing through a
room called Sala Rotonda.
And this room,
it looks actually very
similar to the Pantheon
but it's much smaller.
There is a hole in the middle of the dome
and then this gigantic sculpture
that looks like a giant
bowl in the middle.
It's also a collection of
Egyptian art and mummies.
(smooth tempo music)
We just moved through the Vatican museum.
It's series of hallways and corridors
and not only are there
just amazing sculptures
on both sides as well as
different exhibits and galleries
but if you look up, you
will notice paintings
and decorations and it's just
a museum within a museum,
of a museum.
We have entered into the maps gallery
and this is a long hall that includes maps
which are painted on both sides.
There are topographical maps
which dates back to around 1580.
(soft tempo music)
I'm now walking through the Raphael Rooms
which are a series of four rooms
which contain just incredibly
beautiful and detailed Frescos
which were painted by Raphael.
One of the most famous paintings Frescos
in the Raphael Rooms is
The School of Athens.
It's right behind me and
it was painted in 1509
and it's within the room of the Segnatura.
(upbeat tempo music)
We are about to enter the
place that nobody misses
when they visit the
museums at the Vatican.
(people chatting in background)
I think that's the only
place in the whole museum
where you're not allowed to video or photo
but it is a...
It's not a huge chapel but
the ceiling is extremely high
and it can fit about 2,000
people from what I read
but you look up and the
walls and on the ceiling
and it is just...
All of those paintings by Michelangelo,
the Frescos that you have seen in photos,
it's incredible to gaze
into those paintings
and those Frescos.
What struck me is how high the ceiling is
and then just looking up
and you can just almost fall into a dream
looking at the Sistine Chapel ceiling.
(upbeat tempo music)
We are on our way out of the museum
and going down the famous
spiral staircase now.
It took us a little over two hours
and I think we went pretty fast.
You can definitely spend
a lot more time in there
if you took more time to
look at all of the art work
and the galleries and the paintings.
We are now walking over
to St. Peter's Basilica.
One of the things I want
to do is to climb the dome.
Michelangelo's famous dome
on the top of St. Peter's Basilica.
So we got in the line for the dome
and I think it is a separate line
from entering into the
actual main Basilica.
So that security point ended up getting us
into the Basilica as well.
I thought it was just
gonna get us into the dome.
So we're going to enter the Basilica first
and then go to the dome afterwards.
(soft percussion music)
It is massive in here
and I can see the dome up ahead
and I can see the rays of sunshine
shinning down through the dome.
St. Peter's Basilica
was designed by Bramante
and also Michelangelo
and it is one of the most impressive sites
in the Vatican city.
Especially notable for its dome.
I'm gonna go climb the dome now
and hopefully get some great
views of Rome from here.
And the amount of marble and the carvings
and sculptures that it took
to create this Basilica
is mind blowing.
(upbeat tempo music)
I just got my ticket.
I am going to climb the
stairs to the top of the dome.
It is a total of 551 steps to the top.
So here we go. Here we start.
(upbeat tempo music)
As busy and packed as the Basilica is,
I'm in the staircase now
and it's completely quiet.
There's nobody else here
and I should also mention
that you can take the elevator
at least part of the way up
and then just climb a little bit.
I just took a few minutes
and I've come to some
outdoor courtyard level.
I didn't even know we
were going to have a view
from the top of the dome
but on the inside of the dome.
Wow, this is awesome, you can see below.
(upbeat tempo music)
Made it to that first level
and those are some amazing
views of the church from above
but now climbing the circular
staircase to the cupola.
It's a pretty tight staircase.
I just made it to the top of the dome
and that took exactly 13 minutes
and there were some
amazing spiral staircases.
(upbeat tempo music)
From the top here, you have
a full 360 view of Rome
so you could walk around the dome.
You can see the edges of
the dome going downwards,
sloping downwards.
And of course you have a
whole view, an entire view,
of St. Peters square from above.
(upbeat tempo music)
(bell rings)
The 360 views of Rome were amazing
and also just the hike up
the stairs to get to the top
was also a lot of fun.
I would highly recommend
fishing out the extra money
when you come to St. Peters.
We are walking to the bus stop
and gonna try to take the
bus to the Jewish ghetto
for dinner tonight.
Oh and how convenient.
The bus that we need to take
pulled up right as we got here.
(upbeat tempo music)
And it should be just
a short walk from here
to the Jewish area.
(upbeat tempo music)
I don't know too much about the influence
and the history of Jews in Rome
but I do know that there
has been a Jewish influence
for many years
and this Jewish area of Rome
was officially established back in 1555.
There are a number of different
Jewish Italian restaurants
in this area.
I chose to come to one called Nonna Betta.
- [Ying] Thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you.
One of the most famous Roman Jewish dishes
or it's kind of like a appetizer starter
is a fried artichoke.
They are deep fried so they're crispy.
You can see that little
bit of salt on top.
This looks fantastic.
You can actually see how
the inside is gonna be nice
and probable soft while the
outside is gonna be crispy
and crunchy.
Let me try to grab all
those layers together.
Oh yeah, the inside is
creamy like cooked eggplant
and then those outer layers are crispy
and a little bit chewy
and then it's just nicely salted.
Actually, those outer
leaves are the artichoke.
They were a little too chewy to chew
so I probably ate it wrong
because it's an artichoke
so it has those really chewy,
outer leaf-like things of the artichoke
so the inside is really soft
and then you sort of eat all
that meat from those leaves.
I think I approached the artichoke
a little wrong in the first place
because I was thinking that,
because it's fried,
those would all be soft
but they're still a little bit chewy
but what you do so you can
just grab those crispy bits
and then...
Just like any artichoke,
still bite off all of that
gooey soft bit from the bottom.
And you can eat the crispy
piece of the artichoke as well
but definitely don't make
the mistake like I did
and take half that artichoke in one bite
or you won't be able to chew it.
That's for sure.
And also to begin with
we got a cup of pasta.
And this is, I think it's the
Nonna Betta special pasta.
Let me try to work on my
pasta twirling skills.
I think it's a type of minced meat sauce.
Yeah, that's really nice too
and it's mostly tomato based
but it has a little bit
of a creaminess to it
so I'm not sure what else is in there.
Really good with those noodles
and then just with little
bits of minced meat.
Let me get one more bite of this.
This is excellent.
I think I'm getting
better at my pasta twirl.
But I definitely need a lot of work.
Main course has arrived.
This is codfish prepared Nonna Betta style
and it comes with pistachios and pine nuts
and I'm not sure what all this sauce is
but this looks delicious
and it came bubbling over.
Looks like a very rich sauce.
It should still be very hot.
As moments ago it was bubbling.
Yeah, that taste very buttery
and it has a nutty
flavor from the pine nuts
and the pistachio.
And I love those edges of the fish.
They're slightly caramelized
within this pan as well.
I saw oxtail on the menu
and I have a soft spot in my
heart for oxtail so I had to.
This is a nice chunk of oxtail
submerged in a tomato sauce.
Let me share with you why
I love oxtail so much.
It is this. (exhales shakily)
The meat just falls. It just pulls off.
Look at that.
Okay I'm gonna mix that
with the tomato sauce.
It's such a wonderful piece.
The meat is so flavorful
and so soft and tender.
That's a very mild tomato sauce.
It's not really tart. Not really sweet.
It's very pleasant.
It just goes well with that tender beef.
That's really good.
That was a wonderful meal.
The artichoke was delicious.
Oh, the pasta was also very good
but I really loved that oxtail.
That was the highlight of the meal for me.
Nice to sit outside and
just relax after a...
It was a good day but a very
tiring day with lots of crowds
and it turned out to be a great day.
I'm gonna to end the
video for today right now.
Thank you all very much for watching.
Please remember to give
this video a thumbs up
if you enjoyed it.
Make sure you leave a comment below
and also make sure you
subscribe for lots more food
and travel videos and I will
see you on the next video.
Thank you again for watching.
(upbeat drum tempo)